alors il est exceptionnel par sa taille
en effet
taille qui ne l'empêchent pas d'être
extrêmement beau aussi très esthétique
donc ces deux facteurs la réunis qui
font que c'est un objet absolument
unique donc pour ce qui est de sa taille
c'est le plus grand cratère en bronze
fin de vases en bronze antique qu'on ait
retrouvé les autres qu'on connaît ce
sont à peu près de 60 m 2 cm là on est
un mètre 64 de hauteur donc c'est
vraiment quelque chose de tout à fait de
tout à fait incroyable et on sait d'où
il provient ça aussi c'est assez
exceptionnel parce que voilà ce qui se
tiennent sur son parcours son origine
son utilité alors c'est un vase qui est
d'origine grecque qui a été fabriqué par
un atelier grecs qui étaient
vraisemblablement installés au sud de
l'italie et il a donc parcouru traversé
une partie de l'europe pour arriver
jusque dans ses territoires de bourgogne
qui à l'époque était occupé par des
celtes donc ce que prouve ce genre de
mobilier et c'est là que tout l'intérêt
scientifique résident c'est que il y
avait des échanges des échanges assez
dense est considérable entre le monde
grec le monde méditerranéen et le monde
de cette europe occidentale le monde
celte de cette europe occidentale alors
on a joué de nombreux objets alors celui
là c'est
le plus beau ou manière mais on a trouvé
beaucoup d'autres objets dans cette
tombe vous pouvez nous en parler
qu'est-ce que ça dénote justement à
qu'il devait faire
alors déjà la fonction de ce vase c'est
de servir à mélanger l'eau et le vin au
cours de la cérémonie du banquier grec
vraisemblablement les celtes ont quand
même adopté sept îles ont un grand goût
pour le vin donc ils ont adopté cette
pratique du basket et ce vase était
placé dans une chambre funéraire
accompagnés de l'ensemble des objets qui
servent à mener une cérémonie de banque
et des coupes une cruche tout ça
provenant du bassin méditerranéen
c'est une tante qui était féminine c'est
de sa grande particularité également ça
veut dire que les femmes à cette époque
là pouvaient atteindre de très très haut
statut social cette femme nomme la
princesse de vix était allongée sur un
char d'apparat couvert d'une couverte
d'une parure absolument exceptionnel
dont un collier en or qui est parmi les
plus beaux de cette période
av note quand même une occupation assez
exceptionnel voilà de la région un
village au possiblement en tout cas
d'occupation voilà intéressante
les fouilles sur le mont lassois sont
toujours en cours on continue les
équipes de fouilles continuent à faire
des découvertes chaque année découverte
qui sont exceptionnelles et on se rend
compte que en dehors de la tombe le site
lui même
était très densément occupé été
aménagé avec des des bâtiments
extrêmement massif qui demande un grand
concours de population et des grandes
connaissances architecturales en inde et
fortifications gigantesque on a des
palais installé au sommet du mont
lassois on a un aménagement de la scène
tout à fait considérable enfin ça veut
dire que l'un la population était
capable de mettre en oeuvre des grands
chantiers collectifs le tout sous la
houlette d'une aristocratie très
certainement extrêmement puissante
c'est finalement à l'heure actuelle
après plus de 60 ans
c'est la grande question qui était la
dame de vix c'est difficile de répondre
à cette question dans la mesure où les
populations celtes sont des populations
sans écriture donc ils ne nous ont pas
transmis de témoignages du tout les
seules informations qu'on puisse tirer
c'est par le biais des analyses
chimiques scientifique archéologique est
donc là en l'occurrence pour la dame de
vix sur les ossements de cette dame elle
même on a fait des analyses adn et
isotopiques qui permettent de penser
qu'elle n'était pas originaire de la
bourgogne actuelle et qu'elle viendrait
plutôt d'un milieu montagnard donc elles
arrivent à l'âge adulte sur ces
territoires pour prendre la place de la
place la plus honorifique de cette
société alors après tous les scénarios
sont imaginables